NIGHT, TUCKER CARLSON TAKES OVER
AN HOUR FROM WASHINGTON, D.C.,
GOOD NIGHT, EVERYONE.
♪ ♪
GOOD EVENING, AND WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
IT'S HARD TO THINK OF AN IDEAL,
MORE AMERICAN THAN THE FREEDOM
OF FOR SPEECH.
WHEN THEY SAY OUR SOLDIERS DIE
AND FIGHT FOR OUR VALUES COME AS
WHAT THEY MEAN OUR FREEDOM TO
SAY WHAT WE THINK IS TRUE,
THAT'S OUR BIRTHRIGHT.
IT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT THING WE
HAVE, THAT WE HAVE EVER HAD.
AND SO FOR GENERATIONS, THERE IS
BIPARTISAN CONSENSUS ABOUT THIS.
IN FACT, LIBERALS WERE AMONG THE
MOST STALWART DEFENDERS OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT, AND GOOD FOR
THEM.
BUT THEN THE LEFT TOOK CONTROL
OF THIS COUNTRY'S INSTITUTIONS.
LIBERALS BECAME THE
ESTABLISHMENT.
THEY HAD ONCE OPPOSED.
AND SUDDENLY, FREE-SPEECH SEEMED
LIKE A CHALLENGE TO THE HIGHLY
PROFITABLE, EXISTING ORDER, THE
ONE THEY WERE GETTING SO RICH
FROM.
SO OUR SCHOOLS BEGAN TO TEACH
OUR CHILDREN THE FREEDOM OF
SPEECH IS A THREAT.
IN FACT, IT'S IMMORAL.
OVER TIME, THE KIDS STARTED TO
BELIEVE IT.
AT THIS POINT, NEARLY 60% OF
YOUNG PEOPLE BELIEVED WE SHOULD
CHANGE THE FIRST AMENDMENT TO
BAN SPEECH THEY DON'T LIKE.
CHANGING AMENDMENTS IS HARD,
TWO-THIRDS OF CONGRESS WOULD
HAVE TO APPROVE A CHANGE LIKE
THAT.
BUT ON CAMPUSES, MANY STUDENTS
AREN'T WAITING FOR CONGRESS TO
ACT.
THEY HAVE DECIDED TO IMPOSE
CENSORSHIP RIGHT NOW.
WATCH, FOR EXAMPLE, KIDS AT THE
PURPORTEDLY IMPRESSIVE
NORTHWESTERN UNIVERSITY TRY TO
BAN JEFF SESSIONS FROM SPEAKING
OUT LOUD.
[CROWD CHANTING]
[BOOS]
>> Tucker: YEAH, THAT'S
NORTHWESTERN.
IT'S FUNNY, IF YOU'RE A
MIDDLE-AGED PARENT AND YOU ARE
AT DINNER PARTIES WITH OTHER
MIDDLE-AGE PARENTS AND THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT -- BRAGGING,
REALLY -- WHAT SCHOOL THEIR KIDS
GO TO.
WELL, CODY GOT INTO NORTHWESTER
NORTHWESTERN.
AND YOU THINK, IT'S PROBABLY
PRETTY IMPRESSIVE, RIGHT?
NO, THAT'S ACTUALLY WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE.
IS NOT IMPRESSIVE AT ALL!
IT'S PATHETIC.
NORTHWESTERN, BY THE WAY, IS
HOME TO THE PRESTIGIOUS
JOURNALISM SCHOOL, AND YET THE
STUDENT NEWSPAPER THEIR
APOLOGIZE FOR DARING TO COVER
THE JEFF SESSIONS EVENT.
THE NEWSPAPER DID.
"NOTHING IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
ENSURING THAT OUR FELLOW
STUDENTS FEEL SAFE -- THE
REPORTERS EXPLAINED -- AS IF
THAT IS A THREAT TO SIT STUDENT
SAFETY.
MEANWHILE, AT HARVARD, THE
SINGLE MOST OVERRATED COLLECTION
OF PEOPLE ON PLANET EARTH,
PASSED A STATEMENT CONDEMNING
THE STUDENT NEWSPAPER ON CAMPUS
BECAUSE, LISTEN TO THIS, IT HAD
DARED TO ASK THE FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY, I.C.E., TO
COMMENT ON A STORY.
THEY DON'T ENDORSED I.C.E., SOME
JUST CALLED UP AND SAID, HEY,
I.C.E., CAN WE GET A COMMENT.
THEY DIDN'T RESPOND OR GIVE
REPLY A COMMENT, BUT IT DIDN'T
MATTER, MORE THAN 650 STUDENTS A
MATTER, MORE THAN 650 STUDENTS T
HARVARD -- HARVARD -- DECIDED TO
PETITION CONDEMNING THE PAPER
FOR CONTACTING I.C.E.
THE YOUNG DEMOCRATS I THINK
STAMP CAMPUS ISSUED A STATEMENT,
"DELIBERATELY CHOOSING TO SPLIT
OUR STUDENTS IN JEOPARDY."
ONE CAMPUS ACTIVIST GROUP IS NOT
URGING A BOYCOTT OF THE
NEWSPAPER BECAUSE CALLING I.C.E.
WAS JUST THAT SCARY.
THAT'S PRETTY FUNNY.
ON THE OTHER HAND, IT'S REALLY
KIND OF OMINOUS, BECAUSE OUR
MERITOCRACY IS ESSENTIALLY
FRAUDULENT, AND OUR SYSTEM IS
COMPLETELY RIGGED FOR THE
BENEFIT OF A FEW.
A LOT OF THESE SHALLOW, NEUROTIC
NARCISSIST THAT WE ARE MAKING
FUN OF TONIGHT WILL, IN THE END,
WIND UP RUNNING THIS COUNTRY.
THOSE PEOPLE WRITHING ON THE
FLOOR ABOUT HOW THEY ARE SO
THREATENED -- YEAH, THEY ARE
GOING TO BE IN CHARGE.
THEY SHOULDN'T BE, BUT BECAUSE
THE SYSTEM IS RIGGED, THEY WILL
BE.
THEY WILL BE MAKING THE
DECISIONS THAT AFFECT YOUR LIFE,
AND THE LIVES OF YOUR CHILDREN
AND GRANDCHILDREN, AND THESE ARE
THE PEOPLE WHO LITERALLY
COULDN'T CARE LESS OF AT THE
FIRST AMENDMENT -- OR ANY
AMENDMENT.
IN FACT, ANY DOCUMENT THAT MIGHT
LIMIT THEIR POWER IN ANY WAY.
THEY CONSIDER THEMSELVES GODS.
AND I WOULD LIKE YOU TO SHUT UP
AND OBEY, AND THEY WILL USE